well joining me now is the author Grace
Blakely and best-selling author of the
war on the West Douglas Murray over in
the states all right Grace look as I've
said repeatedly from the start of this I
have a lot of sympathy and agreement
with the cause of just stop oil I think
climate change is real I think there are
real problems facing this planet that we
need to deal with and so on but these
protests the way they're going about
them they are not bringing people with
them they are alienating the very people
they should be trying to persuade I
don't get it the more they do it the
more they're infuriating the public I
don't see anyone saying great they've
ruined my day I must come and join them
they've already achieved their aim which
is to get us to talk about it you know
half the time that I come on shows the
lead item is something to do with the
culture wars it's you know something
about trans rights or some bathroom
issue or whatever and we've just had the
hottest week recorded in history we've
seen temperatures in Europe rise to
Heights that we've never seen in history
these people literally want to set the
agenda and that is what they're doing
and the thing that scares me the most
we've had a lot of debates in the past
about free speech about actually you
know the state overstepping the mark and
when I see videos like that of people
literally you know the arms of the state
literally dragging people off the
streets and saying you're not allowed to
be here you should be doing this but
they're allowed that's worrying about it
but that strikes me as a threat to civil
liberties no but this is this is where
the problem is because I've got no
problem exercising their right into Free
Speech or peaceful protest I don't think
they have a right to ruin to everyone
well no no to ruin people's fun days out
they've saved maybe all year to go and
see at the cricket or the flower show or
whatever it may be I don't think
Ordinary People should have their days
ruined in that way yes nor do I nor do I
think they should be blocking roads like
Vauxhall Bridge which lead down to one
of them to be finished
lead down to one of the busiest
hospitals in London if not the country I
don't think they should be stopping
people going to and from hospitals
there's no legitimate reason to be doing
that
these people are aware of the fact that
the main like segment of people who are
dying from climate breakdown are
extremely poor people who live in the
global South places like the north of
India but Pakistan
um that area of the world where you've
seen temperatures get up to like
temperatures that scientists say it is
not possible for human habitation why
aren't they protesting over there well
because they live here and we are the
ones we are the countries that have
historically admitted the most
is the countries that are in the global
South where poor people are dying why do
we never see them in China we the
biggest polluters in the world we have
the power in this country in Europe in
America in the most powerful countries
in the world in the richest countries in
the world to change things China has
actually done a lot already 98 of them
China
are the biggest polluter in the world
and you never see Incredible or any just
stop all protesters in China how did we
get rich you know why because in China
they get a very different treatment
let me go to Douglas uh Douglas I'm not
about you I just find them unbelievably
irritating and increasingly so I think
there are a bunch of attention Seekers
who love just getting in the papers and
that's fine but why is the state and the
police tolerating it in the way that we
seem to be
well I'd go slightly further than your
peers I mean they are a sort of end time
apocalyptic cultist movement of a kind
that londoners and others have seen
throughout history people who go
jibbering through the streets screaming
about the imminence of the apocalypse
and I don't have much time for their
views and I think that their method of
protest increasingly of course means
that uh more and more members of the
public don't have much time for their
views freedom of speech of course
everyone defends that freedom of protest
everyone defends it but you do not have
a right I I have strong views and a
whole range of things I don't have the
right to go and sit in the middle of the
M24 and tell everyone else uh to go you
know hang whilst I decide to tell them
how they should go about their day or
ruin their day I'd be hauled off the
motorway in a moment and quite rightly
so that the freedom to protest doesn't
extend to disrupting the lives of
everyday people trying to go about their
business
and I I just I just can't understand why
they think that they're advancing their
cause uh uh I I at any rate think that
we still haven't had one even reasonable
person uh emerge from the just stop oil
and etc etc movement every time you get
one on there is a gibbering wreck well
also they get very abusive very quickly
and turn it all very personal when in
fact I try and explain I don't think
your methods are working but I agree
with a lot of the message and so it's a
campaign I think we get much more public
support if they weren't just being so
deliberately irritating to the public
and obstructive to the Public's ability
to go about your day-to-day life I mean
I think that incident today where you
saw a guy who's in a car with his
apparently his pregnant partner and they
get I think hit by a lorry behind them
so it's a collision a crash and she gets
out this pregnant lady is demonstrating
the thing and this guy clearly loses his
rag now the violence he then commits is
unacceptable and most people would agree
with that but I can certainly understand
why he's reached a point of boiling rage
and yeah well where are the police here
this protest has been going on for God
knows how long that morning why are the
police not intervened to stop this
particular incident then happening it's
because of the guidance that the British
police have had in recent years has
consistently been to protect the
protesters from the general public
rather rather than uh protecting the
general public from having their lives
repeatedly remember what happened we had
protests around the murder of Sarah
everard do you remember the police
treatment of those women there yeah I
remember very well in fact and this
continuously happens quite a lot we have
astonishingly now Draconian rules about
protest and it was not that long ago I
remember where you know a lot of the
subjects and debates that we had been
having was about are the left snowflakes
they want to shut everyone down they
want to cancel everyone we you know want
to protect Free Speech what happened to
the Free Speech Defenders the right to
protest is genuinely at risk
in this country
equivalent to them causing literally as
in today with this incident that was a
false equivalent right there incredibly
reminded when you say oh people are
trying to go about their day and there
are people basically literally standing
here saying all I want to do is
highlight the fact that there are going
to be Millions hundreds of millions of
people who will die if we don't change
course right now and you say but look we
all have we all have strong views we all
have strong views on a wide range of
subjects as it happens the policing of
the Sarah Everett case was it was a
classic case of the police getting it
wrong everybody admits that a
commissioner had to step down after it
that was people protesting peacefully as
it happened during a period of lockdown
but the point is with with the with the
just of oil people is they do have a
kind of protection because it seems that
the advice that the police have
repeatedly given uh the the leader of
the police forces in Britain has been
that because climate change has become
such an obsession of so many people in
Britain you might lose public uh
Sympathy for the police if the police
were seen to be cracking down we've got
to move on to the second party I'm going
to move on but I all I would say is I
think it's time the police got these
protesters off busy Street honestly I
think otherwise otherwise what you're
going to see I'm seeing a rising number
of incidents of the public yeah taking
the Law into their own hands and we're
going to end up we're going to end up in
a very bad situation which will be a lot
worse than the video we saw today I can
guarantee it because someone is stopping
someone getting their you know their
wife may be dying and they're racing at
a hospital and they get stopped by just
stop oil protests there's going to be a
very unpleasantness most people on the
right are actually very illiberal and
this is actually going to be interesting
when we move on to this next thing
everyone says we want a small state but
when it's the state stamping itself
thank you Grace